scene three take one  hi hello  buenos noches  uh you need to live somewhere  hey hey you know john milner  curt henders look you sure you don't  want to ride somewhere  did anybody ever tell you that you look  just like connie stevens  no you do really i mean just like connie  stevens i met her once  for real yeah at a dick clark road show  you uh really think i look like her yeah  no [ __ ]  i'm sorry i mean you know i'm not just  handing you a line i think you look like  connie stevens  what's your name debbie i always thought  i looked like uh  sandra d yeah her too  this your car yeah i'm terry the two  uh they call me terry the tiger  it's really tough looking uh what school  do you go to  dewey hey man can it lay rubber huh oh  oh yeah  yeah it's got a 327 chevy mill uh six  strombergs  [ __ ] and tough and gold i just uh love  the feel of techno poster  yeah well come on in i'll let you feel  it i mean touch it  the upholstery okay